on the completion of my own physics
degree I would like to enlighten others
on what content you can expect to be
involved when studying physics you will
start off with broad courses with titles
that cover most of the areas you will
spend the next years going into more
depth about these areas include
introductory mechanics waves
thermodynamics electromagnetism the
special theory of relativity and the
quantum theory of matter to pass these
courses you will need to understand how
to pull information out of a question
and plug it into a formula you
conveniently spotted on a formula sheet
practice and understanding helps but
there is a certain distance you can
freestyle with educated guesses and a
process of elimination you need enough
algebra and trigonometry to be able to
rearrange these equations to get any
variable you want the next year
relativity becomes calculating the
dynamics of particles traveling near the
speed of light and getting your head
around space-time transformations and
different reference friends quantum
theory becomes solving the Schrodinger
equation waves become optical matrices
mechanics is supposed to be
understanding how a gyroscope works but
I still don't think I do
electromagnetism is the connection that
electrons move at relativistic speeds
and people will keep mentioning Fourier
series
you will write long lab reports for
experiments that almost make sense and
that will either bring you and your
classmates together or drive you apart
in New Zealand a physics degree is three
years and in my third year I was exposed
to the world of lattices that make up
materials there are equations to predict
gases and particles with lots of names
there are two big pillar courses that
were both tough and rewarding classical
mechanics and advanced quantum mechanics
classical mechanics looks at everyday
objects and translates them into the
language of lagrangian's and
Hamiltonians where energy and symmetries
can reveal solutions to complex problems
it touches on a new description of
special relativity with tensors quantum
mechanics starts to be written and
directed and you talk more about
commutations observables and spin you
will usually have the chance to do your
own research project for a semester if
you are lucky thus we'll be working with
a supervisor on a real problem in
physics and applying some of what you've
learned and some of your own ideas to
doing real research if you are unlucky
you'll be given some fake problem that
student toil over every year and write a
mess of code in the process
just enrolling in a course and existing
in the lectures won't get you a physics
degree you actually have to learn the
content by third year you will be given
less and less resources and expected
more to derive anything you can't
remember at many times it will seem like
there is too much to be done and that it
is impossible to learn enough of it you
certainly need to be able to apply a bit
of minimum effort maximum gain recognize
what needs to be done and don't toil
over details that aren't important much
of the learning process seemed
inefficient but you need to work out how
to work the most efficiently in that
environment
I have graduated from my degree feeling
like I know very little physics you are
exposed to many different areas and the
problems I were given and had time to
work on were only a subset of what could
have been done going further you can
choose to specialize in one or more
areas but go on other days where one
could be a true expert on all of physics
I'm happy to answer any questions from
people wanting to go down the same path
and good luck with your studies